yeah welcome to this video playing
against a guy from Thailand okay d4 and
done let's play a Queen's pawn opening
here the Torah attack don't want to play
the Queen's Own gambit all the time this
is some quite quite decent alternative
usually leading to too quiet quieter
positions but why dumb certainly can can
play this so we'll just continue
developing him
so at some point I need to get active
otherwise it's simply too tame
yeah with a six it seemed that he was
concerned about Bishop basics not sure I
would have played that don't think so
actually ok so in this this looks like
we will have the typical hanging pawns
yep he's playing c5 so we've got hanging
pawns
k let's grip
now you can take with the night it's not
it's not terrible night d to c 5 okay
this is much more much more common yeah
how to get pressure I think I want to
regroup here this night on g3 and
mm-hmm
didn't did you expect that at all since
I even playable okay I'll take care
somehow this looks we address this is
unprotected pieces always raise
suspicion okay let's just go here attack
the night intending night see 4694 b6
these kind of ideas if he goes 934 if
I've I can take it for and Queen to h5
I'll drop back here not sure with them
there may be 132 night
okay so how to continue now all all
noise but yeah this is so this looks
like an inviting square 96 night f5 to
d6 yeah now night f5 to the 6 it looks a
very tempting but it's not clear that
it's really am bleeding too much let's
just turn improve the position a bit
check
now to f5 maybe should I play a 4mm
I don't want him to play for I had I had
not be sick sir Knight b6 on this hour
at some certainly slightly better for me
in some way but probably am I didn't
play in the best possible way this
intense night f5 on g seven and 96
Knight c3 i also have roop t7 as a
possible good answer yeah night back
night f5 maybe night at five threatening
the Queen was check so he takes on g4 I
take on his seven this must be would be
a good good exchange for me and if he
goes back on a fade maybe night h6 is
actually playable night h6 king age 70 k
doesn't let him
I have funny too funny trickier 95 c 6
yeah but but but but isn't there some
some refutation of this besides just
taking hmm don't see it ok probably I
just I should just take
to go rook v5 now and grab the ANC porn
yeah okay King d5 i take f of the night
at least he cannot move the sea porn
after this and that may be threatening
night be three on 97
so
Knight takes rook takes rook takes the
exchanges that place night to be 6m so
probably need to go here
yeah I cannot go see for it's a pin
night to d3m the system has IDM I will
try to play f3 to fight against a night
on d 393 f3
check
I take it here then is now this tall is
too strong don't want dad so maybe night
be three now try to win the poor now
okay okay there isn't a maid somewhere
right it looks looks somewhat shaky I
don't see I don't see a maid though
gets two passports now
time morning hmm yeah this was probably
not the most efficient way to to go
about that yeah but he didn't have any
time I could win on time for once that's
well yeah this was maybe technically not
so efficient I should probably win this
without much fuss I mean this until
until now this was certainly okay maybe
here I can now play play better before
yeah maybe this is a bit too early yeah
well okay the time was on my side to
this time thanks for watching